number six uh an approach to learning in
the cloud bring your existing knowledge
around application development and think
of various factors that are unique to
Cloud development number seven start
with foundational courses that give you
a broad overview of cloud providers and
their services number eight Target a
certification bring focus and discipline
to achieving it put a date on it and
find a study group or colleagues that
will work with you through towards that
Certification Number Nine build your
portfolio focus on implementing and
developing a solution to Cloud publish
these learnings let these be the start
of your artifacts that you can show to a
prospective employer and number 10
referral works best reach out into your
community and your network share your
latest learnings and artifacts with them
see if they can put you into a referral
those were my top 10 tips to get your
first Cloud job if the was ever a better
time to get into Cloud it is now so get
out there and apply